the way pitbull talks about how he was
growing up listening to tony robbins in
the car with his mom driving down and
she was doing what she was doing and he
found a way to get out and he did this
and he did that in his driving
responsibility
that messaging is a very strong
messaging that the hispanic community
can uh
attach to versus
hey
they don't do anything for us they don't
do anything for this first of all
america doesn't owe anybody anything i
agree okay agree you you use your work
ethic that you have you can do anything
you want to do in america obviously
there's you're not going to be the next
lebron james if you can't jump 46 inches
but this is america or if your dad
didn't get you into harvard even though
you had a c average because he was uh uh
an alum there and has connections so
let's let's let's be honest about this
path
there is something to say about a
country that right now is allowing not
the finest to become successful but the
ones who come here with deep i know
there's guys like you and and me
i i came from poverty who are you
alluding to though who are you leading
to the guys that go to harvard like who
no i'm talking about i'm talking about
uh you know us wanting to make elon musk
a hero uh his dad owned a diamond mine i
mean come on let's face it he is that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean that he
grew up poor that doesn't mean he grew
up rich but
there is a difference to be fair between
a guy who comes to this country has to
really work his butt off to make it and
these guys who had it on easy street and
are looking at poor people primary river
rick crime mia flippin river
you chose to come to this country go to
another country let me get this straight
so you just said you come to this
country and this country
has to give you to the people that have
been here for a while it's like me
saying no no no no no no no you
misunderstood me that's what you're
saying no no no no what i'm saying that
they have an advantage they should have
an advantage no no what i'm saying is
that there's an argument that still
exists that there's some things about
our country that we can fix to make sure
everybody has an equal plan it's not
going to happen though it's just not
going to happen bro and i'm telling you
right now
and it doesn't have to
that simple it doesn't have to improve
look uh for me
we came from iran to us the us gave us a
green card we came in u.s doesn't owe me
[ __ ] except for the green card they gave
me that's it i don't need to have the
same advantage or the same equal
opportunity at john f kennedy's grandson
i don't need to have that i agree yeah
so i agree so i am your story yeah my
parents made ten thousand dollars
combined yeah fewer poverty i get that
but that story needs to be told not the
story of we need to figure out a way to
make it equal it's not going to happen
yeah it's not going to happen like well
it's just not for me to say hey it's
unfair that you know we need to make it
equal that lebron's kids can play
basketball because they're yeah i'm
totally okay with that i'm totally okay
with what if they're only five feet tall
but but the point so something like
shannon sharp says one time he says look
i understand the argument i was born
with this body yep i'm a bad i got a
badass body and it's it's unequal
opportunity to you and i versus shannon
sharp you look at the guy he's just got
it right so what we're going to say hey
work out less hey do me a favor do a
little bit less legs can you run a
little slower can you no that's not this
is how it was created so for us to come
here and be able to compete
elon musk was an immigrant when he came
here and elon musk was able to build a
company and we should actually
get the kids again this goes back to
conversation we had a few months ago
where we have to be careful who we
uh turn our turn into hero where our
kids aspire to be if we demonize
people
that are heroes our kids don't want to
be like those people so let me just say
this yeah let me just say this maybe
maybe this is the way i should present
my argument pushing back on you sure
that it's all about yeah we're all equal
and everybody's the same and you know we
all get to the same place and you know
it's all about your merit which i
understand and if it's a meritocracy and
if it's truly a meritocracy i'm all for
it but if we live in a country where a
specific
company
can get subsidies from the government
because they lobbied certain politicians
and those politicians accepted the money
and then allowed that company to have an
advantage over my company
in a corrupt way
then we got to fix that and some of that
is happening in america today well
you're talking about lobbying and
corrupt uh i'm talking about if you
could make the argument that everybody
has no way that pat's going to disagree
with you on that that's something that
is
advocates against non-stop
exactly two weeks
six weeks ago i'm so against what the
lobbyists are doing but yeah exactly so
we so all i'm saying is within our
system there are advantages for certain
people have certain money okay those are
two different stories i took it out of
the immigrant basis
i get that what i think those are two
different stories what i think your
perspective is and and this is just me
you know sitting on your right for two
years now it's
all you owe me once you let me in the
country is the opportunity to succeed or
fail yeah just you let me in and you
know they say nobody cares work harder
that's basically your perspective no
before you let me in thank you it's on
me now and pat your your mom and dad
that's his license right
they had to wait in line and they had to
wait till they get their card and they
came in here yeah right
yeah but by the way absolutely we lived
at a refugee camp for a year and a half
by the way you know that everyone at
this table has the same story
my fa my family led uh fled eastern
europe in the 1920s and all settled here
in america your family fled cuba it's
family fun parents came on a boat
exactly for 30 days immigration gets
complicated though guys and that's why i
keep going back to we need a system to
make it make sense because right now it
doesn't make sense and here's what
happens right now i'll give you an
example there's a company in dalton
georgia it is the carpet mill
manufacturing place of the entire world
when their workers all left or died or
got old from the appalachians who were
here from world war ii their kids said
dad mom i don't want to work at the mill
yeah i don't want that job so the entire
industry was about to dry up that
industry found a way to go to mexico and
recruit people who came to this country
to save the carpet mill industry which
is now thriving once again in dalton
georgia i went there and i talked to the
people in dalton georgia i said what do
you think of these people they said at
first we were very concerned but now you
know the guy who runs the dry cleaner
the guy who's a chamber of the chamber
of commerce guy says
they come into work earlier they leave
late they always pay their bills on time
they filled up our churches they're
great to have in this community so
and here is a company that illegally
went to mexico and recruited
undocumented immigrants to refill their
positions that americans apparently
didn't want
there's a story there that tells us
something i'm not sure what it is but i
think part of that story is the business
industry some people on the right or on
the left would say look at those people
those business people in dalton georgia
those bastards look what they did but
yet at the same time they help our
country become better by getting these
people here so
we need a system that allows the people
of dalton georgia those businesses to do
that correctly and legally i tell you
what though i think i think does that
make sense yeah but but i think the
community that wins there is the
hispanic community because so if if
people who are born in america let's
just say they're white and they don't
want to do the work of 17 bucks an hour
at target don't do it i'll do it right
i'll take that job it's totally fine
i'll take that job that's my dad but
here's the difference here's the
difference
the the
in the military when you get out of the
military sometimes the challenge with
vets is
they get out they've been conditioned to
be government employees
and when they get out they've learned
work ethic they've learned to work
together as a team they've learned all
this stuff but they're small thinkers so
they get a job at the ups after they
come out of the military i made it hey i
get those additional 10 points on the
test i take hey i go become a cop hey
i'll go become a firefighter i'll go
become this i've made it and that's it
and that's all i do no problem
but you learned the most difficult thing
to be able to compete in marketplaces
which is working hard working as a team
in leadership that on free enterprise
can help you do a lot so the challenge
becomes hispanics are willing to do
those jobs you got to think a little bit
bigger and the hispanic voices like
yourself like the ramoses like those
people out there have to say hey why
don't you go compete with musk
instead of saying
poor you you can't compete with musk bo
stop saying that i can't stand it when
people say stuff like that to me when i
was a kid coming up because i'm supposed
to be afraid of somebody stop saying
that kind of stuff did i hit a nerve
with this guy no no i should not have
said that the point the only the point
i'm trying i get your point the point
i'm like when i went to india i went to
india and i spoke in india four years
ago five years ago and i'm speaking at
iit institute it's a it's like they're
mit which is an insane school 5 000
people are sitting there the chairman of
the state bank of india which is
actually chairwoman arundhati bashari
420 000 employees i believe they have
some 240 000 employees they have then
divyang turakia who's a young
billionaire him and his brother on the
cover of forbes and i'm speaking with
these guys and i said look here's a few
things here's what's about to happen you
guys gotta realize you have a bigger
audience your average age is 24 25 26
you're the youngest china is 36 and
we're 36 china's 38 they're aging you're
not you're young you're learning about
capitalism you got a guy modi who is
letting you go out there and compete
in a few years decade or two there's
going to be someone showing up now that
you're rich you're wealthy your economy
is kicking everyone's ass to say
socialism the better way raise taxes all
these other policies gonna start making
you feel sorry for yourself and don't
you can compete with everybody go
compete don't let any freaking news guy
politician any other person make you
feel you cannot so for me a great the
voices of the hispanic community the
leaders need to say hey what's so
special about elon musk go beat them
correct what's so special about this guy
go beat him what's so special about
obama go beat him be a president younger
than him instead of saying well you know
you know how it is it's not fair no no
no no go whoop their asses
because half the battle is somebody
believing in me that i can't pull it off
it's all it takes that's all i'm saying
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]